from the moment I saw Margo Roth
Spiegelman I was madly in love Margo and
I were practically strangers until this
one night look there go I need to borrow
your car what I have nine things I need
to do tonight and more than half of them
require getaway driver congratulations
on Paper Towns really really lovely film
thanks a lot
which parts of Margo's character - do
you relate to the most
so many there's a couple main ones
though like being fearless I definitely
was that as a kid I definitely had to go
through the ages of me being different
ages and picking out bits that I thought
was who did her character some being
fearless of Stephanie aya when I was
younger adventure thrill seeker that's
probably me now a couple of different
things but Margaery
very confident and is very wise for her
age I think when I was 18 I thought I
knew everything but I was wrong
did you do a lot of jumping in and out
of windows as a child um oh I never
lived in a suburb so not as many as I
should have
I loved climbing trees a lot though so
that was something I did and what was it
like being part of a John Green project
amazing John's writing is incredible
obviously The Fault in Our Stars is
completely heartbreaking and almost was
so sad to watch my kind of regretted
after it was so sad but his writing is
so descriptive and philosophical and
beautiful and really hits teenagers on
the head not in a dangerous way but
really gets their own point and even for
adults I think it's really nostalgic
book and his characters are just
wonderful so being a part of it it's
something to to sweet time is who and
I don't find Margo it's all for nothing
um do you feel like there's more
pressure starting out and acting
considering you're so well-known in
fashion already um there's definitely
pressure it's to be an actor you know
it's kinda it's easier for no one to
know you are and then you play different
roles because they're like where they
even from I've realized I'm from England
so there's always gonna be
oh she's English then let's try and spot
the problems than the American accent
you know there's always going to be the
the difference between me as Who I am
and then as an actor it's harder but
it's also been a good stepping stone in
a way and here you're kind of heroes in
acting and what would your dream role be
ah I'm gonna keep going with extra few
levels I think those are super important
and really really great to play I would
love to play so historico walls or maybe
roles in the future like the first
Formula one woman driver or like a
female politician like Gloria Steinem
would be really cool I think Meryl
Streep's one of my favorite actresses
she's so she does so many different
roles always completely the opposite and
amazing then she's wicked she just seems
like a great person to hang out with
cool and what's the difference kind of
getting into the mood to walk out on the
catwalk and getting into character when
you're on Sara
the film like this I'm before I go on a
cat will go I'm literally [ __ ] a
brick it's horrifying
I never it's the most terrifying thing
the world I don't know why I put myself
through so much but acting it's you're
just getting into the role I think I
spend my time in her makeup chair kind
of just getting into character once
you're in it it's it's far it's just
that you know you're in it I guess but
you're being character you have to be
prepared so if you're not that's why
your lovers
you